LeBron this guy he's the poster child
for playing with different looks and
different things and different fields
and vibes and colors and designs and he
has a lot of rings we see him often
wearing two wide diamond bands one vivid
yellow diamonds and one white diamonds
they're two rows each he carries that
off flawlessly they're amazing
I'm David Allen 25-year master jeweler
and diamond tier making custom jewelry
here in New York City today we're going
to talk about men's wedding ring
men's wedding bands and wedding rings
were not even considered for a very long
time until the 1940s men generally
didn't wear it the only jewelry you
might see on a man was his watch it's
only recently that the the men's band
whether it's his wedding band or his
engagement band has become really
popular notion and something in pop
culture in culture that has any kind of
trend and fashion attached to it it's a
really really new thing the David
Beckham is wearing super traditional
yellow gold that rings about three and a
half maybe four millimeters in width and
it's very very round that's a really
classic classic right Henry Goulding
wearing something very similar a little
bit wider it just looks great on him
with that classic clean watch his crisp
you know white t-shirt and suit it just
fits his style so you have Nick Jonas in
Kanye West wearing very similar rings
dead flat on the top with a 90 degree
angle on a flat side that's a real edge
too at this rate that's a much more
modern look to a thin wedding band
you've taken that old notion of a thin
gold end and you've made a much more
stark and hanging it on which gives it a
bit more of a modern feel to it so what
we regard as the traditional wedding
band today is
actually not the wedding band that we
recognize as normal for men to wear
modern times didn't actually start to be
a tradition until after World War two
around that time when men were going off
to war they put on bands on their left
ring finger to remember their loved ones
so this was for non married couples and
married couples became a comfortable
thing that people regarded as a special
way to commemorate a relationship and
that's when it began to stick as what we
have as the traditional wedding band the
wide band is something that is
relatively new we've seen this come more
common over the last 10 maybe 15 years
and then you see on Ryan Reynolds for
instance that's about nine millimeters
wide
give or take on jay-z that's probably
close to nine or ten as well this is
something we're seeing more and more of
you see in these two bands they're
slightly different shapes they're both
little bit different alloys of yellow
gold a one as Ryan is quite a bit richer
yellow and on jay-z it's a bit of a
paler yellow it's just a style thing as
well it's not a quality thing at all but
these wider bands they look great in any
shape or design that that they're made
in as well
so Ryan Reynolds ring is hammered so
this is done by taking a tool called a
ball-peen hammer as a round head on the
front and you tap hammer the piece all
over the place as uniformly as you can
and it gives these very slight
indentations all over the ring and it
becomes a surface design with surface
texture jay-z's ring he has a brushed
finish so you take a an abrasive and the
way we do it is we put the finished ring
after it's been polished on a
motor-driven spindle and we with a rough
emery paper the sandpaper we left the
ring spin and we put this matte finish
around the whole ring Dwyane Wade's ring
is a much more modern look for a wide
band as well this ring was in all
likelihood machine made you see that it
has on its edges about a one and a half
millimeter beveled edge that looks
highly polished so this will
is cut out of a piece of extruded tube
and cut to width and then with
stationary tools as the ring spun it was
cut to that shape so mixed metals are
another great trend we're seeing a lot
of see on denzel he's wearing two really
thin bands stacked together one white
one yellow so probably platinum and
eighteen karat yellow gold by the look
of it this builds great texture this
also gives him the ability to wear his
ring in a couple of different ways he
can wear just his gold ring just his
white ring where the yellow white white
yellow he can play wrong with this any
way you want and it builds a great lock
great texture great collar play Steph
Curry has a great ring also that is a
yellow gold band with a strip of
platinum
I'm sure that's platinum because the
contrast of the white gold after a
plating will rub off eventually
it's called rhodium rubs away pretty
quickly would make these colors kind of
mush together but here you have the
stark contrast of the very very white
platinum and the really nice rich yellow
of the 18 karat yellow gold making a
wonderful 2-tone ring for him Russell
Wilson is wearing moderately widely it
looks like it's about seven millimeters
also it has white gold or platinum in
the center and a bit of a twist and
yellow gold rim on either side this is
something we are seeing more and more of
also these two tone rings with texture
brought to the to the face of the piece
as well Russell Westbrook always sharp
he's got very clean style with his
clothing you can see he brings that
style to his jewelry as well that party
I love ring is as clean and simple and
elegant
it really fits his style very well the
cartier love BAM this is a ring that was
born of the cartier love bracelet which
has been arguably Cartier his most
popular piece of jewelry for very long
time and has an interesting history the
love bracelet itself was designed and
inspired by the chastity belt of Dave
past right so you know if you know that
they have to be taken off with a
screwdriver
the cartier love ring is a single piece
of jewelry it doesn't have to be screwed
on and off it still comes from the same
the same place kind of neat to see
especially men who sometimes fight the
notion of a wedding band wearing
something that well they may or may not
know the history of it that it came from
such a heavy notion but the design is
great and it can show up in lots of
different ways Spike Lee is wearing it
really is a beautiful way here his looks
white gold or platinum and he's wearing
him next to a thinner yellow gold down
we see spike stacking his rings all the
time and this is a great look for him
furthermore spike has just his ring up a
little bit with one diamond where that
screw head would be otherwise it might
be a back around the entirety of the
ring but you see that ring both ways it
could have one stone that could have
stones every other or all the way around
there's another way you will often see
these Cartier love rings with pave-set
diamonds all over them so it's not just
one stone in the dead center where the
screw head was but you have little pave
diamonds around the rest of the surface
so John Legend is wearing a little more
of an old-school wedding band in that we
see this sort of pave diamond detail on
a band where you have one strip of
pave-set diamonds in the center of the
ring with a contrasting color metal on
the outside so it tends to be like this
where the base of the band is yellow
gold and the center is white diamonds
but today as men are really letting
loose with their style choices you'll
see this in lots of different iterations
black diamonds with white metal with
rose gold with all sorts of different
color combinations Tyrese has an amazing
set of stack rings on right now this is
straight-up
clean and classic look chance the rapper
is wearing a great ring here also clean
sleek lines this is called channel set
where the the whims of metal around the
edge of the ring or push delicately over
the edges of the stone so you have a
very very clean sleek looking ring the
ring has no surface detailing whatsoever
and on the top you just see the diamonds
they look like they're floating in the
middle of this channel wall so very
classic very clean really minimal so
Pusha T is wearing an amazing ring this
is what's loosely referred to as an
eternity band big stones set with shared
prongs going all the way around the ring
this is a style that has mostly been for
women over the last 10 20 30 years now
it's something guys are wearing all the
time
even when men started wearing diamonds
often it was simply a bad weather a
simple ban or not it was a ban now you
are seeing this trend where men are
wearing these Center stones like a
woman's traditional engagement ring
poochy mean this guy to wear some
jewelry I think every man should be
comfortable wearing a big stone like
this but not everybody's there yet I
think you have to start somewhere so so
maybe your first piece of jewelry won't
be a 20 carat diamond and that's okay
but the way Gucci wears these things
he's so comfortable in his own skin that
he pulls these these two rings off
together so beautifully
I mean his engagement ring is this giant
pear-shaped diamond with diamonds all
around the band on the prongs everywhere
in his wedding band that humor is right
behind it is a big eternity band with
pave-set diamonds on it as well so you
have a big diamonds little diamonds
texture shape incredible this set that
he wears off set is not afraid to wear
big diamonds nor is his wife car TV and
he bought her in a hundred carat heart
shape diamond for her birthday he's got
for himself here massive and will cut
diamonds into giant stone that sits atop
and all emerald cut and pave set
diamonds all the way around it just
suits him suits him really well these
are well seven figures there's no
question about when you get to 20 30
plus carats of a high quality you're
talking about million plus to all the
Rings for sure
so for diamond cuts the modern round
brilliant cut which is a highly
engineered very symmetrical 58 facet
diamond that was developed in the 1940s
to maximize the brilliance of a stone it
has become the industry standard it's
70% of what is sold for diamonds in the
industry so by far the standard stone
you have the emerald cut diamond which
is a step cut stone a very clean
geometric deco looking feel to it a
rectangular shape with cut off corners
you know the square would cut often
referred to as an asscher-cut similar
but it's the square the radiant cut the
princess cut these are all geometrical
as well but unlike the emerald cut in
the asscher-cut they have lots and lots
of facets that make the stones super
brilliant sometimes even more brilliant
than this round brilliant cut you have
the cushion cut which has become
massively popular today think of a
pillow shape if you will soft sides soft
rounded corners ovals but become
massively popular in the last two years
last year thirty percent of our
engagement rings that we made were oval
and then there's all these specialty
cuts which are much much less common
so this thorn ring that Iman Shumpert
and Chris Paul are both wearing has
become very popular trend especially
amongst the NBA players it's a very cool
look so the designer says that meaning
behind these rings is the ability to
break free from any struggle in your
life and just keep pushing forward so I
love the notion of this ring and the
design is super cool and as
nontraditional was one might think they
are they're an easy option for a wedding
band
it's great to put a band that has other
meaning to it on for your wedding day
President Obama I mean the
quintessential cool he's taken here the
jumping-off point of a simple not too
wide not too thin yellow gold band and
turned it up on its head
it has ribbed lines going through it it
has perpendicular sets of wires on the
ring it's been said people of you know
started tripping about all president
obama doesn't wear his wedding bands why
and he made it very clear that he
doesn't wear his wedding band when he's
out in public shaking a lot of hands
because it's so very special to him he
doesn't want anything to have it with it
I totally respect that LeBron this guy
he's the poster child for playing with
different looks and different things in
different fields and vibes and colors
and designs and he has a lot of rings we
see him often wearing two wide diamond
bands on vivid yellow diamonds and one
white diamonds they're two rows each he
carries that off flawlessly they're
amazing and then you see him in a pair
of Cartier love bounds one is black and
gold so that's white gold with black
rhodium it's called black rhodium but
it's actually ruthenium plating on there
and it's electroplated to the ring and
stay there for a while it'll rub off
eventually but you can have him replated
and then next to it is a smaller stack
two cartier love band with pave diamonds
all great great set he really has fun
with his jewelry love to see that
[Music]
the men's wedding ring it's a trend that
is here to stay I'm certain of it this
world has opened up too many guys are
seeing all of these cool innovative
different things being done in popular
culture now that's when men tend to
start to understand that they can go
outside of their own box and Buck what
has been a trend or the the simple basic
thing that they've seen their whole
lives and start to do things that have
meaning to them that are really personal
to them so anything from having your
wedding band be something really cool
really different stacking multiple bands
different callers to getting yourself
into a wardrobe of bands that you're
constantly switching about and having
fun with and changing on a regular basis
this this is here to stay I'm sure